después del último vídeo si pusieron
mucha atención en porque el robot no
estaba retrocediendo seguro se dieron
cuenta de que fue porque no había
suficiente fricción entre el eje del
motor y la superficie sobre la cual
estaba corriendo así que lo que voy a
hacer es colocar un poco de cinta de
aislar a los ejes de los motores para
incrementar la cantidad de presión entre
el motor y la superficie de la mesa así
que cuando el robot choque contra algo
sea capaz de retroceder inmediatamente y
ahora deberíamos de ver un incremento
tanto en la velocidad del movimiento del
robot y su habilidad para reaccionar a
su entorno que lo rodea así que llegó el
momento de ver las diferencias
pueden ver que ahora está frenético
realmente desea salir definitivamente ha
mejorado su habilidad para reaccionar a
su entorno ya los obstáculos que
enfrentan y además mejoró la velocidad
con la que se mueve